now you don't really get a picture of
what this looks like right I mean I know
roughly what cubics are supposed to do I
know they're gonna sort of start down
here and end up there they get a wee
little bit in the middle but it kind of
needs better pictures don't know okay
and the important features that I do
first are the roots now I know what they
are
have the x-intercepts I don't know why
this that is just six that's an easy
picture yet but the x-intercepts are
hard I need some kind of factorization
okay so how about factorizes see I need
to take advantage of this fact appear
here and plug in values until I get zero
right now when you get given questions
like this because we know it like you're
limited so like I can calculate off I'd
be brave you will get one where the
first factor that you can find should be
relatively smaller okay the first number
I always try is one right so I'm gonna
test P of one in fact this is exactly
the way I've lighted it okay I say test
because I'm trying to find something
like I don't know what the answer will
be so I say P of one there are ones that
limit first values I'm trying because
it's easy right I'm gonna get one take
away four plus one plus six
okay now remember what I'm trying to
find is zero right I don't actually care
what the actual value is if it's not
zero zero is what I want that would give
me a factor now I don't need to do any
more operations in that to know that's
not zero can you see that things aren't
gonna balance out okay so all I say is
it's not zero like I don't actually need
to know what the value is I just need to
know if it's zero or not okay I've
tested one you have to twice in front of
you you can keep on going off you kiss
one two three those are pretty common
values the test right so I'm gonna test
p.m. - okay and again this is a bit
harder but it's not as nice at all I'm
gonna get let's see eight take away 4
times 4 which is 16 plus 2 plus 6 does
that look like it's going to be
zero is it work so what I've got here is
zero so I found a factor that's
excellent
right if P of 2 is 0 therefore X minus 2
is a factor and I think it's really
important to state that right like it
shows why you've been sort of randomly
doing things it's so that you can tag up
around here ok all right a factor of n
so what I do with this down I could do
right now right I don't want to randomly
synthetically all long divide this by
anything I want to do something where I
know I'm going to get everybody zero so
now like if you give it right to is the
zero of this in fact it's just a number
then I snuck in here before
and then I want my coefficients which
are read back for me okay
what's the first step it's a bit just
write down the leading coefficient and
then if you comes our iterating step
right multiply add multiply add multiply
add sir multiply add points
wait such a rapid would you - director
yes I you know again I do it I'm
second-guessing myself I help multiply
and then add and they're multiplying
then add you care with that there's that
remainder zero that I was so desperately
hungry for okay so therefore my answer
here is going to be x squared minus 2x
minus 3 yeah so the reason why I've got
this now is so I can do a division
transformation statement I can say P of
X or Y really is going to be the divisor
times the questions and I don't have a
remainder I mean I'd rather made up but
it's zero
okay and what's great about this stuff
transform the hog problem gross Specter
eyes of cubic into an easy problem
factorize a quadratic that's really easy
to do you can tell me the pair of
numbers right now does that what now you
can see by the way how do we tried
instead of doing P of to had I try and P
of negative one that should also give me
a remainder zero right so then the fact
you try first is its most one it would
work out just the same now you know this
I'm not going to live at the point you
can graph this very very simply okay
having factorize it now I know what our
all of those numbers what are the
significant to those those are give me
the roots right I've got roots had
negative one two and three
yeah maybe give one to you and okay so
now I just need to draw a cubic that's
gonna pass through negative one two and
three some looks to be something like
that is that a game that's and I know
where the intercept is because it's just
that guy
so you see this process really it just
makes an intimate your question is like
this it's so simple to go through and
it's very efficient as well okay oh no
okay if you if you agree on a question
like this right I could ask a logical
next step which is okay knowing this I
can differentiate off the first
derivative I can find those turning
points now that you know calculus that
is a very like that's a quick next
question that I would ask but if all I
was asked to do is describe just before
so that's it the roots were the
important feature right and I need to go
through I'm emphasizing this process
Suton get those exactly right that make
sense
but I was a compression I mean I could
easily ask apartment a differentiate by
the stationary points and then plot them
onto your graph that'll be a fairly
common question begins